Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Mystery Drama film called “Love
Stoppage Time”. Watch out and take care!
Takashi Aiba is a student working hard to get
into a medical university. He is in one of his
classes when suddenly at quarter past twelve,
everything around him stops moving. His
classmates remain frozen in their seats and
so does his teacher. Takashi cannot believe his
eyes, he looks around confused and starts to laugh
believing he is being pranked. He walks to the
front of the class unsettled by the silence.
When he walks outside and sees the entire school
is frozen, he realizes it is not a prank. Somehow,
time has stopped for everyone, except for him.
Takashi gets on his bicycle and rides to the
nearby park. As he travels further, he registers
he might be the only person who can move.
He stops after seeing droplets of water frozen
in a water fountain. When he tries to touch it,
the water falls all over him. From the other side
of the pond, a girl laughs at him, revealing that
she can also move. Takashi is about to call
her but he suddenly gets back to the class,
where he was before time froze. He is completely
dry as if he had never gotten in the pond. Takashi
is shocked at the experience but cannot tell
anyone because no one would believe him.
That night, he returns home still thinking
of the strange events of the day. He asks
his father about his day but doesn’t get any
answers. Takashi’s father is disappointed in him
because he was unsuccessful in getting into
his desired university. The following day,
at 12:15 pm, he is in the library. He bumps into
a guy and sees that the book he dropped has frozen
mid-air. Realizing that it is happening again, he
runs to the park to meet the girl from yesterday.
When he doesn’t find her there, he goes to
her school that he recognizes by the uniform
she was wearing. After looking for some minutes,
he finds her lying down in the school’s garden.
He wakes her up but the girl thinks he is a
pervert. Takashi apologizes and claims that
he looked for her because he felt alone. After
finding out they are the only ones who can move,
she agrees to accompany him. The pair talks about
the time stopping but has no clue what is causing
it and why they are the only ones who can move.
All of a sudden, the girl notices a driver has
fallen asleep and is about to drive into some
children crossing the road. She tries to wake
him up to no avail. Takashi knows no matter what
they do to stop him, things will go back to how
they were after the time is reset. Hence,
he looks for the driver's number in the car
and remembers it. As soon as the time resets,
he calls him, hoping to wake the man up.
Following that, he runs to the location and sees
that the children are safe. The girl also arrives
there and praises his quick thinking. They promise
to meet again tomorrow. Before leaving, the girl
tells him that her name is Tokine Shinomiya.
The next day, they meet at the park again.
Shinomiya is drawing a sketch which Takashi thinks
is useless because it will disappear when time
resets. Still, Shinomiya believes that the picture
will be embedded in her mind so it doesn’t matter.
The two then go on a bike ride through the city
and end up in a field. As they talk, they name the
pausing of the time “loss time”. Takashi wants
to spend more time with her but is too shy to
ask her out. Shinomiya senses this and says that
they should meet the next day and go on a date.
Later that day, Takashi is cooking while singing,
clearly in a good mood. However, it changes when
he notices his father Seiji behind him. As they
talk, we find out that Takashi’s mother died of
an illness when he was nine but Seiji didn’t come
to visit her in the hospital. Ever since then,
their relationship hasn’t been the same.
The next day, Shinomiya and Takashi meet at the
park for their date. She claims that she wants to
play on the trampoline because she is embarrassed
to do it when people are watching. Takashi
watches her play like a child and cannot help
but smile. Following that, he lays out the food he
has cooked for her. At first, Shinomiya hesitates
to eat it saying that she is on a diet. Takashi
reminds her that after the loss time is over,
she will go back to being hungry so she can eat
as much as she wants. The two enjoy the food
together while talking about different things.
Eventually, they get into an argument when Takashi
says he is giving up on his dreams. Shinomiya
calls him lazy, making him walk away from her.
He accidentally pushes her to the ground when
suddenly, the time restarts. Somewhere else in
a hospital, doctor Asami walks into a room to
his sick wife. She has been sick for several
years and the chances of her getting well are
low. Like Shinomiya, she also loves to sketch.
Asami takes care of her dearly but she feels
like she is a burden to him. The following day,
Takashi is in his room reading manga when the
time stops again. He runs to the park and sees
Shinomiya waiting for him. Both of them apologize
to each other and reconcile. They decide to meet
at his home the following day. Takashi tells
her that his goal in life is to be a doctor.
They go for a bicycle ride and end up in the
same field again. Takashi moves forward to kiss
her but the time resets just then, and he ends up
back in his room. In the meantime, Asami and his
wife’s relationship takes a turn when she says she
doesn’t want to be with him anymore. He is shocked
and asks her why, even though he knows the reason.
She tells him that she is being transferred to a
hospice health care place tomorrow and wants to
live however she wants for the time she has left.
Asami tries to reason with her but she dismisses
him. The next day, Shinomiya knocks on Takashi’s
door for their date. She is wearing a beautiful
dress that leaves him speechless. He welcomes her
in and compliments her, making Shinomiya blush. He
has prepared several dishes for them that excite
her. Before sitting down to eat, he gives her a
pair of fancy chopsticks as a gift. The two enjoy
the food in silence. Later, Takashi asks Shinomiya
what she plans to be in the future. She seems to
avoid the question and talks about a time capsule
that she buried when she was little. The capsule
contained papers where she had written her dreams
and aspirations but she doesn’t remember them now.
Takashi suggests they dig it up but it turns out
that the field is someone’s front yard now.
After the meal, they enjoy a chocolate cake
together. Takashi invites her to a firework
display at night but she claims that she cannot
see him anymore. A shocked Takashi asks her why
but the time resets and he never gets to know the
answer. The following day when time freezes again,
he looks for her all around but doesn’t find her.
Later, he asks her classmates who inform him that
she is in the hospital getting treated
for a deadly disease. Takashi quickly
runs to the hospital and finds out that she
has a condition called Wilson's disease.
The chances of her survival are low because only
a liver transplant can save her. All of her family
have gotten tested but none of their liver is a
match to her. Moreover, to perform the transplant,
the donor has to be a family member, so she has
lost the hope for survival. She also reveals
that the day she found out that she won’t get a
donor is also the day the loss time started.
Takashi insists he will take a test to see if
his liver matches her but Shinomiya thinks it
is fruitless. When he doesn’t back up, she tells
him she has only six months to live, so doesn’t
want to see him anymore. At home, Takashi googles
Wilson's disease and reads several articles about
it. He finds out that a person suffering from the
disease isn’t allowed to eat chocolate, shrimp,
and seaweed, everything that he had been feeding
her till now. Shinomiya was able to enjoy the food
she liked when she was with him. After finding
this out, he rushes to the hospital again.
He walks into Doctor Asami and asks him to save
her at any cost. To his surprise, the doctor asks
him if time stops for them as well. They go to
the rooftop to talk about the matter. It is then
revealed that Asami and his wife also went through
the same experience as Takashi and Shinomiya did.
Asami’s wife was suffering from a terminal
disease that needed a liver transplant.
Suddenly, the two started to experience loss time
and met each other. It was almost like god's way
of telling them that their liver matched and Asami
could help her survive. Since both pairs’ story is
very similar, he believes that Takashi’s liver
will also be a match to Shinomiya. However,
for a living transplant, there are several rules
that need to be followed. First of all, the donor
must be the recipient’s relative. This can be
managed if the two get married. But still, Takashi
cannot donate organs before the age of twenty.
Their last chance would be to hope that Shinomiya
survives for one more year until he can legally
donate his liver. But the doctor claims that she
can hardly survive for six months at the rate her
health is currently deteriorating. Following the
interaction with Asami, Takashi sits beside
Shinomiya, looking through her sketchbook.
All of her sketches are of the memories
they made together; like the water fountain
where they first saw each other and the
lunch box that he made for her. But what
catches his attention is a sketch of himself.
When Takashi returns home at night, he asks his
father Seiji how his mother was able to survive
for more time than the doctors had predicted.
He is informed that she used to say she won’t die
before Seiji fulfilled his dream to construct a
bridge. She held on for a few months but sadly
couldn’t see the finished product. During her
death, Seiji was at the construction site trying
to complete it quickly because it was the only
thing he could do for her. Hearing this, Takashi
forgives his father for not being there when she
passed away. The next day when time freezes, he
goes to the house where Shinomiya had buried her
time capsule. He has made it his mission to find
the box no matter what. He digs different areas
of the yard each day and keeps track using a map.
After digging for several days, he finally finds
the box and runs to the hospital to give it to
her. Shinomiya says he shouldn’t have worked
that hard but she is secretly delighted to have
the box back. On looking through it, she finds
drawings of her as a baker, a florist, and so
on. Takashi also shows her the sheet that says
his liver matches to her which means they met for
a reason. To her surprise, he kneels down and asks
her to marry him. Shinomiya cries, overwhelmed by
the gesture but Takashi promises to save her.
Asami has talked to the ethics community of the
hospital who allow Takashi to donate under the
consent of his parents. He asks permission from
his father, urging him to sign the consent papers.
He claims that only forty percent of his liver
will be used, so he will only suffer from mild
discomfort. But if it means saving Shinomiya’s
life, he is willing to do anything. Still, Seiji
doesn’t permit him to make the reckless decision.
The following day is the day Takashi and Shinomiya
get married. The hospital is being decorated
for the ceremony. Takashi puts two watches on a
platform as a replacement for their wedding rings.
Asami comments that he feels like he is going back
in time because his wedding was also very similar.
To Takashi’s surprise, his father arrives at the
hospital with signed papers, happy that his
son has made a decision to save someone’s life.
However, the story takes a turn when Takashi finds
Shinomiya unconscious in her hospital room.
She is taken to the ICU immediately but the
doctors can do nothing as she goes into a coma.
Takashi finds a letter addressed to him where
Shinomiya thanks him for making her life better.
She also expresses her love for him for the first
time in the letter. When the clock hits 12:15,
the time doesn’t pause. Takashi believes
that this means Shinomiya has passed away
but the doctor informs him that there is still a
chance. Cut to a few weeks later. Takashi wakes
up on a hospital bed next to Shinomiya after the
organ transplant. They both are alive and well.
The couple holds hands, thankful for their health.
Somewhere else, Asami and his wife are watching
the sea. Asami makes her understand that she is
not a burden on him, in fact, she makes his life
better. The two reconcile and he assures her he
will find a way for them to be together again.
In the last scene, we see Takashi and
Shinomiya having lunch at the park on
Shinomiya’s seventeenth birthday.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.